morning everybody it is uh seven o'clock
very welcome to join us this morning
wherever you're watching us around the
world welcome to the breakfast show on
sky
fresh evidence of attacks on kiev this
morning and an extraordinary act of
defiance from an employee of russian
state tv very very brave woman see what
she did coming up in just a moment we'll
also talk to the foreign office minister
james cleverley shortly and get his view
on how long president putin can carry on
plus we'll speak to the former foreign
secretary jack straw and labour's lisa
nandi will also hopefully speak to
ukraine's deputy prime minister and then
at 9 30 ukraine's ambassador to the uk
will be here sitting on this sofa it's a
packed show it's tuesday the 15th of
march
more explosions heard in kiev just
before sunrises fighting continues to in
the east of the country
these are live images from kiev we're
hearing a series of russian strikes hit
a residential neighborhood at least one
person has been killed
hitting back ukrainian military releases
this image of them striking a russian
tank as president zielinski says
progress in peace talks has been pretty
good
they're lying to you the russian state
tv employee arrested after interrupting
a live broadcast in protest against the
war
and a very good morning from south
ukraine the port of odessa ceasefire
negotiations continue today but this
place is thought to be russia's next
target
as roman abramovich is spotted at an
airport in israel reports he may now
have flown to moscow as the uk fast
tracks new laws to sanction more
oligarchs
calls for a fracking u-turn will speak
to the boss of cuadrilla as the prime
minister says dependence on russian oil
and gas has left us open to blackmail
from putin mps have criticized him
turning to saudi
can i press the minister does she not
see any contradiction between rightly
ending dependence on putin's russia for
fossil fuels but then seeking to replace
them by going cack in hand to another
murderous tyrant
also on the programme for you this
morning trying to escape will speak to a
british man struggling to get his young
daughter and his ex-partner out of
moldova and into the uk
[Music]
and raising a bow to ukraine will speak
to a ukrainian and a british violinist
who performed with almost a hundred
other musicians in a symphony of
solidarity
[Music]
hello everyone ukraine's president says
progress in peace talks has been pretty
good but overnight there's reported
evidence of explosions in two ukrainian
cities and a russian strike that's hit a
residential neighborhood in kiev
here's what uh happened overnight
russian forces have continued shelling
suburbs around the capital kiev with
loud blast hoods before sunrise
explosions and gunfire were also heard
overnight in kharkiv in the northeast of
the country
these are the live images coming to us
here at sky center from kiev this
morning a smoking residential building a
russian strike hitting that neighborhood
this morning around 18 miles from the
city center at least one person has been
killed others are thought to be possibly
trapped inside that smoldering building
the ukraine military say they were
artillery strikes
let's bring you the key developments
this morning should we president
zielenski has described progress in
peace talks with russia as pretty good
the uk is set to sanction more oligarchs
today as new laws to tackle dirty
russian money are fast tracked through
parliament
the prime minister boris johnson says
the west made a terrible mistake by
continuing to rely on russian oil and
gas after it invaded crimea in 2014 and
it's left as open to blackmail from
putin prime minister heading to saudi
arabia this evening to explore other oil
options
and more than 43 000 people have so far
signed up to take in ukrainians under
the government's homes for refugee
scheme in the uk as martha kellner
reports
even as ukraine's leader hailed progress
in peace talks russia's warplanes
continued a relentless bombardment
across the country
the second city of kharkiv coming under
heavy fire last night
there is a crackdown on opponents of
this war in russia
but from the bleakness came this
breathtaking act of bravery
in a country where denouncing the
invasion of ukraine is now a crime
this employee interrupting one of
russia's most watched news programmes
its propaganda the sign reads
they are lying to you here
stop the warshi chants as the anchor
tries to drown her out
marina of cyankova was arrested shortly
afterwards but she had pre-recorded this
message
propaganda
it was a glimpse of opposition to this
war within russia even if much of it has
been scared into silence
horror at the relentless bombardment of
their ukrainian neighbours
on the outskirts of key new strikes have
brought fresh devastation
residents of this ruined apartment block
picking through the wreckage of their
lives
president zielenski said talks between
ukraine and russia would resume today as
he made a direct plea to russian
soldiers
we need you
we hear what you really think about this
senseless war about this disgrace and
about your state
the fragile diplomatic hope remains but
as this war enters its 20th day
the suffering of the ukrainian people
multiplies
it's difficult to compute loss
on this scale
martha counter sky news
well the foreign office minister james
cleverley joining us now mr cleverley
good morning to you uh let's just start
with um the nato base that we heard
about over um the last couple of days uh
reports in this morning's newspapers
that uh up to uh three uh former um
military personnel have died in that
explosion do we know anything more about
that
well uh i don't have details on the
individuals that have been
injured and hurt or whether or not
they're british nationals obviously if
there are british nationals involved the
uk foreign office will
be there to support
we do remind people that the travel
advice is that they shouldn't be going
to ukraine we completely understand
the urge to help and be supportive but
obviously
we we we are telling people it is not
safe to travel to ukraine but obviously
if british nationals have been hurt or
killed the the government is there to
support but the government can't confirm
this morning whether or not british
nationals have perished
no indeed i can't i can't uh i i can't
speak about
those details i don't have
that detail at the moment but as i say
the uk government is there to support
people if they do need our help but we
do urge people whether they're
tempted to help militarily or whether
they are trying to
be
supportive in a humanitarian sense are
our advice is that people should not be
going to ukraine uh that there are other
ways that they can help and uh we we
advise them to donate to a recognized
charity rather than putting themselves
at risk okay explosions in kiev again
overnight it looks as though another
residential building has been hit it
looks as though the russians are getting
quite desperate um hitting buildings
like this just to clarify we do it every
day that's a war crime is it
yes so the targeting of uh civilians or
civilian infrastructure is uh is a war
crime
uh the the situation in ukraine is is
terrible and it's obvious that the the
russian military are not achieving
the goals that they set themselves
they're not achieving the goals that
vladimir putin has a set for them the
defense by the ukrainians is
is is is amazing and we continue
to support whether it be through
humanitarian support economic support
and those defensive military equipments
that we have uh provided the ukrainian
armed forces
to that end um an aid to a close aid to
president putin victor
zolotov says that uh progress is slower
than expected surprising that uh someone
close to putin would actually
acknowledge that we also believe that
russia is asking for chinese aid that
has been denied by china what's
britain's advice to china we've heard um
what the united states has said they've
warned china against getting involved
well what we're saying to
all countries is that they should
denounce this unprovoked illegal attack
into into ukraine by russia they should
not in any way be supporting russia and
we urge countries to join the uk and the
international community in condemning
and sanctioning russia to choke off the
finances which are funding putin's war
effort there is no justification at all
for this attack and we urge uh china and
all countries around the world to
denounce it and absolutely not to
support it of course you're a foreign
office minister we told china that we
told them to butt out of this war
well we have made it clear to
all countries around the world
that
that they should condemn this action we
saw at the united nations an
unprecedented scale in that vote at the
general assembly against the actions
that russia have taken we are seeing
every day more countries joining the uh
joining the the countries that are
sanctioning
russian individuals vladimir putin and
the people around him and what we do is
we're urging everybody to make it very
very clear that they oppose this
invasion that they will take action that
they will sanction
putin and those people around him and
they will prevent him from pursuing this
as i say this completely unjustified war
against ukraine and has china done that
have they given us that guarantee
well uh
i mean china's statements are in the uh
in the public domain uh we feel that
that countries should be really
unequivocal in their uh opposition to
what's going on they should condemn a
lot of countries did so at the united
nations we would like everybody to
continue pushing russia
as you said in your introduction we're
introducing now
or rather just last night legislation
was passed which enables us to apply
even more sanctions on top of the ones
that we've already applied and what we
want to do is is have the international
community speak with one voice
condemning this attack putting real
financial pressure on to vladimir putin
so that he can no longer pursue this war
of aggression against and i do want to
talk to you about oligarchs in a second
but i just want to clarify copper bottom
it has china guaranteed to the uk that
they will not get involved in the war in
ukraine
well we haven't had that statement from
china um but what we are looking to do
is ensure that china and indeed every
other country around the world is
condemning russia's actions absolutely
not supporting russia in its aggression
against ukraine and indeed sanctioning
russia and putting real financial
pressure on russia that's what we're
calling on the international community
to do that's what we will continue to
push for
until this war comes to a conclusion the
russian forces leave ukraine everything
that the ministry of defense puts out
every morning about this time and
intelligence update as they call it i
just want to share it with our viewers
and i'm
interested to hear your view on this and
and particularly
the second point about reports um
suggesting that russia may seek to stage
a referendum in kirsten an attempt to
legitimize the area as a breakaway uh
republic similar to donetsk what's your
interpretation
of what that means
well it's quite clear that
vladimir putin's original intention was
to have a kind of a lightning war a very
fast war to capture ukraine take heave
and instill uh install rather a puppet
government that is clearly not working
they are failing in those military aims
so it's now quite obvious that they are
that vladimir putin and the russian
military are attempting
some form of legitimacy or justification
for their military actions the uk is
completely clear
ukraine is a sovereign territory they
have a right to protect their own
borders they
you know
a fake faux election to try and justify
russia's aggression to ukraine will be
recognized for exactly what it is and
that is a fake and what we are calling
upon russia to do what we're calling on
putin to do is to end this war and end
it immediately
okay
fact-finding mission continuing there's
so much to talk to you about this
morning i'll crack on an article in the
telegraph this morning from the prime
minister um in which um he talks about
solar he talks about wind he talks about
nuclear he talks about
north sea oil doesn't mention fracking
are we giving up on fracking
well we have uh made it absolutely clear
that
we need to move away from our collective
addiction to hydrocarbon energy the uk
has really led the way we saw this at
cop 26 in glasgow till end of last year
the uk has really led the way in pushing
for alternative energy uh production
moving away from gas moving away from
oil the the situation in ukraine
presents a
unique
uh and terrible uh additional emphasis
to us collectively to move away from our
addiction on uh
hydrocarbons and it's absolutely right
we we we seek to do that
because it's the right thing to do for
the environment and as we're now seeing
it denies russia an incredibly important
source of income that they rely upon to
fund this war
and an answer to my question
well as i say we have made it absolutely
clear that we are looking ultimately to
move away from our hydrocarbons in the
uk we want long-term economically and
ecologically uh sustainable routes
specific decisions on
you know specific means of energy
generation
is for the energy secretary but
ultimately our direction of travel is to
move away from hydrocarbons because as i
say it's the right thing to do for the
environment it's the right thing to do
economically and in this particular
situation with ukraine it's the right
thing to do to deny russia a means of
funding its war effort we've got one of
the heads of the fracking companies on a
little bit later on quadrille they're
looking at sealing their wells as early
as today should they do it or should
they wait
well as i say okay the the uh individual
decisions is a matter for uh the uh the
energy uh department but the point that
i've made is that our direction of
travel in the uk
is to move towards an economically
ecologically and and and and as we're
saying with regard to russia uh uh a
more diplomatically
sustainable model of energy generation
and that is ultimately you were him
would you steal the site today or not
would you steal that well today or not
if you were the head of quadriller to be
honest with you i'm dealing i'm dealing
more i'm focusing more we're trying to
bring the uh the conflict in ukraine to
uh
talking about it as the lead story in
the telegraph today i get the importance
i get the importance i get the
importance of uh securing uh um
energy in the in the short term that is
an incredibly important point and the
prime minister will be speaking to the
international community to to do that
but ultimately
as i have said the real important thing
for us to focus on is ultimately moving
away from our addiction to hydrocarbons
because that's a quick thought about
saudi arabia before i let you go and
ecologically the right thing to do just
a quick thought on saudi before i let
you go here's uh prime minister heading
to saudi arabia later on today they um
killed 81 men
over the weekend we're always told that
we bring up human rights with them every
time we talk to them it's not getting us
very far is it
well
i
used to be the minister for middle east
north africa um the uk has a
long-standing and principled opposition
to the use of the death penalty that is
a conversation that i have had uh with
saudi arabia when i was in this role i
know my uh uh my uh my colleague amanda
milley who's taking over that role she
will have had uh conversations along
those lines our position is absolutely
clear we think it is wrong
as a
as a as a
as a response to a criminal behavior
that is our long-standing principal
position we will have communicated that
to saudi arabia i have no doubt we will
do in response to the executions that
have been recently announced okay but
we'll still do business with them but
sadly we are out of time so we'll have
to pick that up again next time we chat
mr cleverley thank you very much indeed
for joining us thank you
quick look at the front pages for you
know most of which lead on the public's
response to the homes for ukraine scheme
the eye says thousands of british
families have already signed up to host
refugees the sun leads with the same
story saying 43 000 people have offered
to take in those fleeing the conflict
that's also on the front of the daily
mail carrying britain's rush to join a
new scheme is their headline
while the time says the online
registration site crashed shortly after
it opened as people rushed to sign up
the national ukrainian army has released
this footage showing soldiers firing
from an armored vehicle at russian
forces in mariopol the city council said
as of yesterday
2357 people have been killed in the
besieged port city
nick standing by for is in the black sea
port of odessa for us now um hi nick and
we cannot underestimate
how important odessa is to both sides
can we
no it's uh it's hugely important it is a
massive port strategically important
it's important to the economy you have
to see it as one of the sort of major
ports in the ukraine and if the russians
take it then they have control of the
black sea and that is that gives them a
very strong hand and we've been here for
a few days now seeing how they're
defending themselves other port cities
to the east of here like uh mikhail we
visited yesterday half the population
has already uh run from there 500 000
people usually live there 250 000 people
in just over a week have decided to
leave and that is because gradually the
russian military is encircling that port
city and it has been shelling and
bombing there for the last few days and
when we went yesterday we saw that there
are still a lot of people who have not
been
able to leave or can't leave can't
afford to their families are there we
met a grandmother who was looking after
her grandchildren because the parents
worked in a local hospital and they are
just sort of hunkering down
trying to survive this
elsewhere yesterday was a bloody day in
this war uh the capital kiev saw
some really significant shelling
artillery hit a 15-storey apartment
block engulfing it in flames one person
died and many others were trapped our
teams on the ground there reported that
this apartment block this residential
complex was nowhere near
any military sites which leads to
the ever-growing conclusions that the
russian military are targeting civilians
we saw evidence of that in micholia of
yesterday we were driving down a
residential street that where shells had
landed on the roads and all the windows
of all the apartments had been blown out
and people are long gone
from there they dare not stick
around there was some hopeful news from
that city yesterday on our drive-in we
saw about 15 buses all in a fast-moving
convoy packed with people
thankfully those um probably more
probably women and children able to get
out of there to odessa but as you said k
they're going from one dangerous area to
another about 150 cars were able to
be evacuated from mariopol a city that's
been pounded there for nearly two weeks
so there are glimmers of hope as these
humanitarian corridors are opened that
people women and children can get out of
these cities it's heartbreaking when you
meet toddlers in a in a city that is
being shelled knowing that they cannot
escape so peace talks are continuing
today and
and a lot of that talk is trying to
figure out whether humanitarian
corridors can be opened and stay open so
that people can get out of these
dangerous places
okay for now thanks a lot thanks nick
uh well despite the ongoing war in
ukraine residents of odessa are doing
their best to keep spirits high as they
prepare to defend their city from a
russian attack have a look at this
[Music]
ah amazing and so they're taking the
opportunity uh to join together through
the medium of song how lovely chelsea's
football club's owner roman abramovic
has been spotted in public for the first
time since being sanctioned over his
ties to vladimir putin he was seen in
the vip lounge at tel aviv airport where
he departed for istanbul on a private
jet it's thought the billionaire then
flew to moscow mr abramovich said last
week he was selling the club for the
sale has been put on hold due to chelsea
operating under a special government
license and the premier league
disqualifying him as a club director
still to come on the program before you
will get the views of labour's former
foreign secretary jack straw on all
sorts of things
we'll speak to two women who fled
ukraine and are now thousands of miles
away in ireland what happened to them
and then after eight we'll be joined by
the shadow leveling up secretary lisa
nandy very passionate in the house of
commons yesterday you'll find out why at
just after eight o'clock
meantime china's dismissed claims by the
united states that russia has requested
military equipment from beijing as
malicious
misinformation let's find out more tom
standing by for us in beijing and i was
just pressing the foreign minister for
the uk on that very subject as well um
tom and and it i'm not i'm not clear
who's been communicating with china and
what they've been saying
okay yeah i mean you didn't get an
answer from the minister there we
haven't had an answer from china as you
say they dismissed this as malicious
disinformation when it was reported in
multiple media outlets but when it was
reported in those media outlets the what
was reported was that russia had
requested aid from china military and
economic support but we didn't know what
china's response was and there was a
sense perhaps that the u.s and u.s
intelligence was trying to get out ahead
of this to put pressure on china and its
role in this ukraine conflict because so
far china has been on the sidelines and
everyone's been wondering which way it
will go especially because of that deep
friendship between presidents vladimir
putin and xi jinping the president of
china they met here on the eve of the
olympics they talked about a partnership
that knew no limit but i think we are
finding out that there are some limits
and where those limits lie china
rhetorically has firmly been in russia's
camp uh it's been amplifying russia's
concerns it's what it causes legitimate
security concerns it has repeated uh
false information about uh laboratories
in ukraine it says the u.s are running
so in terms of what it's saying um it is
not it is certainly in russia's camp and
it has not condemned russia's invasion
it's refused to even call it an invasion
but in terms of actions we haven't seen
anything concrete and i think that's the
key part of this if china does intervene
on russia's side we'll have effectively
a proxy war in ukraine ukraine and
russia fighting in the middle but the
west and china on either side and that
is a rather nightmarish scenario of a
new cold war but china hasn't gone that
far yet it has blocked shipments of
aircraft parts to russia because it's
worried about secondary sanctions and
china is itself dealing with a surge in
covert cases here it doesn't want to
jeopardize the economic environment any
further so so far it's been a wait and
see approach the thing that might change
that is the close friendship between
putin and xi jinping they share a world
view they both think the dissolution of
the soviet union was a terrible event
for the world and they united in the
belief that the west power is on the way
i think recent events may have convinced
both of those that the west is stronger
than it first appeared especially in
terms of response to ukraine uh but
right now beijing really defined by
inaction rather than anything else just
a quick thought on kovid before i let
you go i'm sure that you've seen that as
of friday all of the remaining travel
covered restrictions uh in england at
least are going to be gone and yet very
different story in some parts of where
you are
yeah okay really different story i mean
this has been fortress uh china when it
comes to kobe the borders have been
sealed for a long time
and they have this zero covered approach
where if there's an outbreak they try
and stamp out very quickly through mass
testing and targeting lockdown but it's
coming under a huge amount of strain now
the cases might not seem that high 5 000
reported yesterday but that is the
highest it's been in two years and the
warriors the trajectory they keep adding
around a thousand every day and it's
spread all over the country so people
are worrying uh whether this is the
moment that omicron breaks through china
and that can have serious effects for
global supply chains as well we've
already seen some factories that produce
iphones shut down as a result of
lockdowns happening and there are
millions of people under lockdown now so
it's a nervous moment for china they're
trying to
beat back uh this recent wave of omicron
because they still have a low rate of
vaccination full vaccination amongst the
elderly people are getting nervous about
this and they are hunkering down for
what might be a long time okay tom for
now thank you
other news for you this morning and as i
was saying all travel restrictions in
the uk are set to be removed completely
whether you're vaccinated or not from
friday no one entering the uk will need
to take a covert test or complete one of
those passenger locator forms that takes
forever this will make the uk one of the
first major economies to end all
coronavirus travel rules talking to the
um travel editor of the daily telegraph
claire irving coming up very shortly
before that let's take a look at these
dramatic pictures from amsterdam skipper
airport of a plane landing in heavy
crosswinds my goodness here we go
[Music]
okay let's get a tight shot of the touch
now shall we because he's gonna grease
it oh look he's got a big smile on his
face look
her face
nervous flyers a very good morning to
you wherever you're watching this
morning he brought that cargo plane down
though beautifully didn't he a qatari
pilot bringing down the airplane at
skipper airport in significant
crosswinds apparently they need to crab
in sideways and flick it round at the
end
not for me thank you
rather sit here
latest employment data for the uk has
just been released what is it saying
helena is here good morning morning okay
so there's lots in there statistics that
tell us what's going on with jobs and
wages essentially a few sort of uh top
lines uh unemployment uh is uh up and
unemployment's down that's good but
actually digging deeper there's a few
other things going on that i think
economists and the government will be
quite worried about firstly and
importantly
wages and how importantly they compare
to inflation so for the second month in
a row now real wages are down compared
to inflation down a whole percentage
point uh in the three months to january
so that's really really significant and
really worrying because we know
inflation is very very high and
essentially if families get to the point
where they feel that they can't spend
their money out in the economy that they
can't afford to do so that's when things
get really worrying from an economic
perspective especially as we are still
theoretically recovering from the
pandemic
so that's a big problem not least as
well because these are the figures for
january and we know that when the
figures for february and march come
through when we start seeing the impacts
in those numbers of the war in ukraine
those huge increases in the price of oil
gas grain unfortunately the situation's
likely to get quite a bit worse one
other thing that's worth pulling out we
haven't spoken that much about it in
recent months we did a lot in the summer
but vacancies that huge labor shortage
quietly continuing to get along a lot
worse so for the first time the number
of vacancies in the economy up over uh
one million three hundred thousand and
that matters too because if companies
can't find workers they have to put
their wages up they in turn have to put
the prices of their goods up that in
turn feeds through to this big
inflationary problem that we're all
seeing and that mismatch between wages
and inflation so there's a lot of stuff
going on that i think the government
will be very worried about that the
chancellor will be uh paying attention
to in his spring statement next week
he's really going to want to be seen to
do something for families okay lovely
thanks helen and thank you and a
reminder that uh our business presenter
ian king is back with a special episode
of ian king live looking at how the war
in ukraine is affecting the global
economy um and that is um tonight for
you actually here on sky news at nine
o'clock this evening nine o'clock this
evening a special programme from our
business presenter ian king live the
global economy
on the news lewis hamilton has revealed
he is in the process of adding his
mother's surname as an additional middle
name it's understood the seven time
formula one world champion he was robbed
of his eighth one
wasn't he
will include labra lestia as a third
middle name along with carl and davidson
rather than it becoming a
double-barreled surname so lewis said he
really wants mom's name to continue on
with the hamilton name
and it's no more hard road for one rock
icon who has taken it upon himself to
fix some of the potholes that plague
britain's roads who are we talking about
sir rod stewart donned a track suit and
high vis as he began repairing potholes
close to his harlow estate in essex
after complaining that they would damage
his ferrari
so he used to dig graves and now he's
mending potholes just in case it damages
the underneath of his ferrari
he posted those pictures
on instagram
still to come on the programme for you
explosions have been heard in kiehm just
before sunrise
as fighting continues to in the east of
the country
the ukrainian military released this
footage of them striking a russian tank
as president zielinski says progress in
peace talks has been pretty good
franciscan teachers
a russian state tv employee is arrested
after interrupting a live broadcast in
protest
against the war
well a short while ago i asked the
foreign office minister james cleverly
whether china had condemned russia's
invasion of ukraine to the uk following
reports that moscow had asked beijing
for help
well we haven't had that statement from
china
but what we are looking to do is ensure
that china and indeed every other
country around the world is
condemning russia's actions absolutely
not supporting russia in its uh
aggression against ukraine and indeed
sanctioning russia and putting real
financial pressure on russia that's what
we're calling on
the international community to do and
that's what we will continue to push for
uh until this war comes to a conclusion
the russian forces leave ukraine
tamara's here good morning what did you
make of what mr cleveland had to say
this morning well he didn't really go
for china which suggests that there may
be talks going on behind the scenes but
he made clear that there have been no
guarantees made by china about what its
role is going to be could it potentially
hold out the prospect of being a
solution to this crisis could china be
the only country to try and get
talk vladimir putin down to try and get
peace talks going in a meaningful way i
think that's what all the world is
wondering but certainly and what we've
seen from um from joe biden you know
rushing to to rome to have talks there
is great concern about what it could
mean if at the reports from u.s
officials are correct that uh russia has
asked china to give it weaponry to
continue this war and that's important
because it looks as though
in fact russian aids have acknowledged
that the onslaught has stalled because
they don't have enough equipment and
they particularly need drones
the west is looking to china to say
don't you dare absolutely that's very
much the message i think the us were
giving don't do it and yes after weeks
of saying it is all going to plan
although we could all see and the uk's
intelligence assessments made clear that
it wasn't we've heard sergey lavrov
raging in those press conferences saying
you don't know what the plan is only we
know what the plan is but you've had
senior people now in russia expressing
doubts about the way the war is going
about the huge losses of life that we
assume are taking place although no
official numbers on those as yet and you
know if china was to enter that the war
inside of russia as tom cheshire was
setting out be a huge call for them it
would effectively be a new cold war so
these are the sorts of considerations at
the moment and of course um boris
johnson is meeting a number of leaders
of nordic and baltic countries today
countries like estonia and latvia
they're all in london having a meeting
this morning and they will be concerned
about whether this conflict might spill
over over their borders from russia and
well and
and uh whether the um
do you apologize about that that's okay
my phone's gonna mind if it's owned um
but uh whether the um whether whether it
could flow over to their boards then
obviously what that means okay i'm going
to let you play with that phone
obviously there's something much more
interesting than what uh i'm saying just
at the moment there we go don't worry
about it um in fact you should see um a
cartoon that is it we'll try and get it
for you cartoon in the times or the
telegraph today i can't remember and
it's got um
putin on a bear
riding up to a dragon that's half
sleeping yes so let's see what happens a
big concern indeed boris johnson also
talking about weaning ourselves off
russian energy today and what that will
mean for people's households we'll talk
about that in tomorrow's take weren't we
at nine o'clock looking forward to it
thank you meantime let's bring in uh the
former labour foreign secretary should
be jack straw hello to mr straw thanks
for joining us i did put it to mr
cleveland about uh what we have said and
what chyna might have said to us tell us
how those back channels work especially
in a situation like this when we are
trying to get them to stay out of a war
that could make the difference between
tens of thousands of people dying and
not
in any acute situation it's essential to
have what you describe as a back channel
and indeed called back channels so those
are confidential
conversations between
diplomats who are trusted only on each
side also have to trust each other
and typically i mean
they take place
completely away from scrutiny and just
give you one example
when um
president obama wanted to reestablish
some relationship with iran which led to
the nuclear deal in 2015 there were two
years of back channel negotiations
between american and iranian officials
which were quotes deniable
but which
uh ensured that when they got to formal
negotiations they actually had more or
less got it pre-cooked as the saying
goes in the diplomatic trade
okay um what do you make of of what
you're hearing then and
the fact that china is saying no we're
not involved at all and how dare you
suggest this and the united states is
saying we can see what's going on what
what role would you play if you were
still uh the uk's foreign secretary what
would be happening behind the scenes
well
what i can see is is that
china has been
looking at the situation
uh it has it has nothing to particularly
to thank the united states for it it's
benefited hugely from
the relaxation of uh
trade
restrictions which took place
30 years ago but the united states and
the west benefits as much as china does
from china's trade and china is a great
nation and one of the things about both
china and these days russia
is this sense that these are nations
which were humiliated
by the west in china's case were
humiliated in russia's case
are being humiliated
as a result of the collapse of
the berlin wall and all that's happened
30 years is on so they don't really feel
their with the the west end of thing on
the other hand
uh the chinese level not stupid
far from it
and their prosperity does indeed depend
on trade with the the west and only a
tiny amount on trade with russia whose
economy is so much smaller
than it is is china's and of course its
population is so much smaller too
so
the chinese be trying to work it out
just and and what they think they've now
decided or should have understood is
that this is a war that uh president
putin is not lost but he's certainly not
winning uh and even if he does quotes
win it will be a a victory which will be
hollow so that's what's going on there
the only in my view i mean i think this
is widely shared
the only man
who could really
push putin into a corner getting off
this um
brutal outrageous adventure of of his
is um the prime the chinese president
and that's of course important you know
for the west for people uh
like our prime minister and the united
states president to push
with the chinese as well
yeah mr shaw we're very lucky to have
you on today because of course foreign
affairs very much
dominating the news headlines we're
hearing that the prime minister our
prime minister is heading to saudi
arabia later on
um today to talk about trying to source
a different
customer a different client when it
comes to oil given the sanctions that
we've got in place against russia but we
know that the saudis
killed 81 people in one day
on saturday uh certainly this weekend
how can we do business with a country
that we bring up um their their
behavior towards fellow human beings and
they continue to do it ever since your
government was in power because of
course you also did business with them
we did
um and it and it's true um
across the world that you're faced with
these
moral hazards
uh so the answer is uh
how do you do business in practice well
with a peg on your nose
um but it's
that here's here's the problem and that
and then there will be people saying
well just refuse to take saudi oil i
mean let me just
point out too by the way
that texas
um the lone star state of the united
states
it too executes a
quite significant number of people and
with a very very rickety
criminal justice system certainly
compared to ours so just point that out
um and and there is a relativitism here
so
when iran which is uh
kills more people judicially than the
other country executes people if they
ever announce this there's huge
condemnation around the world uh if it's
saudi arabia it's muted and if it's
texas on the whole people say nothing
about it
anyway how do you do it um we need saudi
oil i also just say as the world's
waking up we also need iranian oil
and we need venezuelan oil and so
you will have to see not these not these
things put aside altogether
but
frankly twin track negotiations
but
in the case of saudi arabia iran and
venezuela for example those countries
need
hard currency they want to sell more oil
at the highest price they can and
they won't mind at all about
putting russia's nose out of joint if
they can
take a greater market share
of things than uh of their own oil and
gas markets than does russia so that's
what happens
okay just looking at the figures
actually apparently texas executed six
people last year i take your point but
it's significantly fewer
than what uh saudi arabia got up to just
over this weekend let me ask you finally
if i may about fracking um your previous
constituency of course of course up
there in lancashire very much in the
heart of a fracking uh territory
quadrila has to decide whether to start
capping those wells or not given the
situation that we found ourselves in um
should we
cap those wells nonetheless or should we
wait
it depends on the uh geology um i mean
i've never been opposed in principle to
fracking um
uh
and i've seen it operate elsewhere and
and it it's it's not about there's a
huge amount of of
talk about what it does
in in all the countries where fracking
is taking place it's been perfectly okay
the difficulty um
is the geology of that part of
lancashire uh and
it did lead to a number of okay very
minor earthquakes um but you talk about
an earthquake
you think of buildings tumbling down
that happens that there are many more
natural earthquakes of that size than
they have been caused by fracking but
nonetheless
you've got to understand it from the
public's point of view and that
there is real anxiety uh in the in that
part of lancashire
about the geological effects and effects
on their own houses
of uh fracking so that's the issue for
me it's a it's a if you like a practical
one uh rather than uh am i opposed in
principle to fracking why should i be
opposed in principle to fracking it's
another way of getting oil and gas out
of the ground and i'm very much in favor
of all the climate change change
policies which my party is pursuing but
meanwhile
we need a lot of gas and oil we do uh
former foreign secretary we are out of
time it's always great to have you on
the show do you come back more often
thank you very much indeed thank you
thanks a lot
so latest suggestions uh from the
government time and time and time again
is that the uk takes more refugees than
any other country in europe does it
we'll talk about it with an expert in a
moment but first ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky now one of the most
recognizable world leaders with his
trademark army green shirt an unshaven
look and clearly this is rubbing off on
other leaders including
the french president emmanuel macron has
been spotted posing in a hoodie and
jeans a stark departure from his usual
crisp suit and tie
the snap show mr macron fielding calls
from international leaders in paris
elysee palace while bearing a striking
resemblance to the ukrainian leader
anybody would think he was fighting an
election campaign
no the exodus of refugees from ukraine
continues almost three million people
have left the country so far joining us
now is researcher at the university of
oxford's migration observatory peter
walsh hello to you mr walter i heard you
on the radio just yesterday morning um i
also have heard the prime minister many
times from the dispatch box telling us
that more refugees
in europe than anywhere else come to the
united kingdom is that true
well he was quite cautious in the words
he used resettled refugees so that's a
technical term resettled refugees are
those who are identified by the un
typically in refugee camps around the
world and then transferred to
participating countries but actually
that is not the whole picture we settled
refugees make up a relatively small
share about five percent of all those
people who are given asylum related
protection in the uk
and europe the rest the 95 well those
are people who actually have to come to
the uk
to apply for asylum it's not possible to
apply
abroad
so they have to come to the uk apply for
asylum and they are in much bigger
numbers both in the uk
and in europe and when it comes to the
regular asylum application process
the uk ranks about fifth or sixth when
compared with the eu
so and the five percent we're number one
but actually much bigger numbers come
through the regular asylum process what
about the head of population where are
we with that
yeah so some people say actually it
makes sense to adjust by population
because population size although it's a
really
crude measure it gives some indication
of the country's ability to provide
refuge to people and when you adjust the
population the uk falls well down the
list when compared with the eu coming in
at about 20th place
20th
yes and that's when we take into account
both the resettled refugees that the
prime minister was talking about and all
those asylum seekers who traveled to the
eu to claim asylum and are then granted
status 20.
so which countries in in europe should
we be looking at i mean often we hear
about germany but i've i've heard
previously that sweden does very well
when it comes to looking after refugees
it does yeah sweden actually pips us
into the sixth or fifth place germany is
first place
and it's about ten times as many people
it offers century two than the uk and
then there are other countries like
italy like greece like spain like france
they're all ahead of us too in absolute
numbers and then some of the smaller
countries of course per unit population
and i'm guessing also just before i let
you guys absolutely fascinating stuff
turkey turkey um took an awful lot of
kurdish refugees didn't they
a very substantial number it's actually
estimated that there are more refugees
in turkey than any other country in the
world and the latest estimate
four million so very considerable
numbers in turkey although that's a
country we don't really hear so much
about
yeah so what we have to remember is when
the prime minister says we take in more
refugees than any other country in
europe that's true but only if you add
the word
resettlement
yes it is it's that small subset of the
total number of refugees to whom we give
protection it's those resettled refugees
who are selected from camps by the um
and transferred to participate in
countries where on arrival they receive
full refugee status that is absolutely
fascinating stuff isn't it and i'm sure
that our viewers have all learned
something as a benefit of you're not
from a benefit of your knowledge this
morning thank you so much for taking the
time to join us thank you
my pleasure
thank you
it's all about the wording all about the
detail my next guest traveled four days
to flee the conflict in kharkiv leaving
their family behind they're now living
safely in dublin elada and anastasia are
with us now hello ladies thank you for
joining
us hi tell me the story tell me what
happened
uh our story is
that our homeland ukraine uh as you know
nowadays
is under attack of russian bombs and
rockets and our native city uh harco
currently is target uh by the enemy and
as you know civilians are dying every
day our families who stay in harkiff now
they are hiding in a bomb shelters um an
underground station
to avoid russian rockets and bumps
unfortunately
so tell me what took you to dublin
particularly
uh sorry
tell me why particularly you went to
dublin yeah
yeah uh it happened by accident uh our
uh our way was long we had left harkev
and travel to poland firstly uh the
journey to the polish border took us
nearly four days
but we didn't know where we could go
next and we were stuck in poland and we
were in desperation uh because we
couldn't find accommodation and a job in
poland
uh and
we
became stranded in poland and we have
we had no idea um
uh
and that's why with this uh we decided
to go back to ukraine and
um the fact that we are in ireland now
it's just um
i don't know a magic
okay now elada um i know that um you
travel together you're related aren't
you um anastasia is a child psychologist
and it was her work um that
particularly a young mom called let me
just check her name um well tell me tell
me about oxana and what happened
yeah
it's a woman
who helped us um
to help who helped us uh her a little
child uh stephanie uh she was scared and
she was stressed because of the war uh
and aksana fine axana decided to find a
child psychologist
who might be able to give to her child
some recommendation
and consultation
and
aksana
sent requests
as you know uh to find some psychologist
and by the accident um as stacia sold
these requests and anastasia replied
uh to her
message on
they um
they um
started to work with her little girl
okay you know what ladies i'm so pleased
that you're safe and what a terrible
journey that you have had but hopefully
you can start to build a new life in
dublin safe in the knowledge that the
british people are completely behind you
thank you so much
thank you and we wanna uh we wanna um
we wanna send irish people we are so
grateful
to irish people for all the kindness and
hospitality the uh that uh they treat us
with and
our irish family who host us um
in this family we are surrounded by care
by our attention
we could feel family worms and we really
appreciate it and uh um we are attached
to the bottom of our hearts that's
lovely beautiful ladies i'm afraid we're
going to have to leave it there thank
you so much for joining us much
appreciated thank you thank you
let's have a quick look at a couple of
the pictures for you from this morning's
papers just whizzed through them for you
very quickly daily mail has this shot of
what the night sky looks like from the
outskirts of kiev amid heavy russian
bombardment the telegraph has this
dramatic picture of a wild horse in
colorado captured by a us-based scottish
photographer for this year's sonny world
photographer
awards and one more got time for one
more
here we go the times has this absolutely
fantastic picture of a car that was
renovated during lockdown see you at 8.
[Music]